all right welcome back safety blitz you
know the two-time super bowl champ
rodney harrison jack collinsworth rod
let's get into cam newton cam newton had
a good return there's you know i'm back
he's screaming he's doing all this stuff
takes off his helmet the first
play he scores a touchdown
and then he runs into a red hot miami
dolphins team brian flores who you know
well and what happened next
just think about it just think about it
you're at home chilling on a couch all
right and nfl defenses are still
practicing they're still meeting they're
still having engagement with the coaches
talking about how you're going to stop
certain guys and when cam comes off the
couch and he starts at quarterback
it's it's still cam newton but it's a
different version of cam newt it's not
the young athletic cam newton that we're
used to seeing the mvp cam newton no
it's an older cam newton it's a guy
that's still trying to learn the offense
it's a guy that's still so focused on
the offense that he really can't even
read what's going on defensively so to
me this never even made sense to me this
never even made sense he's staring at
the receiver he has to stay away from
javon holland this kid is a a fantastic
safety and he under throws it he makes a
beautiful catch you got to put a little
air in that and once again cam we always
talk about the accuracy issues right he
throws that right to xavier howard i
mean look at this
perfect coverage why are you he's locked
on this man and man this is perfect
coverage why don't you go somewhere else
because cam newton once he gets stuck on
one guy it's hard for him to survey the
field to go to his second read to go to
his third read and if if matt rule i
don't know what he was necessarily
thinking and maybe this was a decision
based off of desperation but at the end
of the day don't you watch film that
rule don't you watch film like don't you
watch the same film that i'm watching
and that every other team in national
football league that didn't give cam an
opportunity now i think he could be a
backup quarterback
but as far as a starter in this league
the game has passed them by
yeah yeah i mean i we we watched the way
that it all unfolded there with new
england so then he comes in and the
first touchdown he scores like when he
pulled off his helmet right away and you
knew it was going to be a free 15-yard
penalty like
to me it was kind of everything we've
known about cam is it's like just like
you know look at me you know like
pointing fingers like pointing at the
back of the jersey the superman like he
just went right back to all that stuff
before he had done anything and that's
with every team in the nfl being like
now we really don't want cam newton to
be our quarterback so i think you hit
the nail on the head which is it was
desperation i mean they were looking for
anything at the quarterback position a
little bit of athleticism maybe he can
complete some passes but this is
somebody who has had multiple
surgeries on his throwing shoulder and
you're starting to see what it's doing
to his accuracy coming out of that arm
so
is it a long-term answer for carolina no
is it a short-term answer for carolina
no is this what i expected to see all
along yes is this what's starting to
happen yes
do you see it getting any better for cam
newton carolina or do you see a pattern
starting to develop like we've really
seen the last couple of years that he's
gotten a chance
they're not going to win i mean they can
probably go
eight and nine or i don't you know
they're not gonna they're not i don't
think they're gonna go to the playoffs
with cam playing quarterback i just
don't think that they can do that um joe
brady hasn't been good he's offensive
coordinator you think about sam darnold
his failure talking about um cam newton
coming in here basically the same thing
between matt rule and joe brady those
guys supposed to be offensive gurus you
would think with the talent that they
have of course they don't have christian
mccaffrey the security blanket but they
still got talent around them and i just
don't understand why this offense has
been so inconsistent
let's get you to our second turn the
page tuesday which is the indianapolis
colts this is another one of those
interesting teams where they have an
incredible ground game carson wentz has
shown some awesome moments what page do
the colts need to turn in your eye
it could be a positive turn it doesn't
have to be a negative term because to me
we watched them against san francisco
when san francisco didn't play their
best football um the coach went down
there and took care of business now
everybody's saying that san francisco is
super bowl bound and they went down
there took care of their um their
business i like what frank wright has
done with carson wentz i see a
completely different carson wentz i see
a guy that's controlling the offense a
guy that um he's not afraid to make
different checks and adjustments and the
biggest thing is throwing the ball down
the field the confident and confidence
in which he's throwing the ball down the
field he's spreading the ball around and
he's not turning it over i think carson
wentz is playing really really good ball
and you know i think frank wright has
given him stability in in philadelphia
he always had to worry about if somebody
was looking over his shoulder and the
fans and things like that he came to
indianapolis frank wright cleared his
mind almost pushed a reset button and
you see a completely different carson
wench i think frank wright has been
great and even though they lost this
game they can still hold their heads
high and they know they can com they can
compete with anybody in the national
football league jack
that's right the colts outplayed them
for most of that game that's the
defending super bowl champ anytime you
can go do that it's pretty darn good i
mean their offensive line is really
talented and i don't even think quentin
nelson is fully healthy yet when i when
i watch quentin nelson play i just
i i'm used to watching him really have
some pop and i don't see that same pop
but this is still one of the premiere
one of the best running games that
you'll see around the nfl i mean that
jonathan taylor coming out of there is
is one heck of a running back you got
t.y hilton pittman jr is having a good
year doyle's having a good year and you
look at the rest of that offensive line
fischer is playing well left tackle
smith is playing well at right tackler
you've got heinz as well as a little bit
of a change up this team's going to be
around i think the colts are going to be
one of those hanging teams that i don't
know that you want to face when it's
cold weather and the ground game becomes
even more important so here's what the
playoff picture looks like in the afc
there in that in the hunt category but
when i look at those in the hunt teams
they may be the most talented group
especially with you know baker mayfield
being heard if baker gets healthy i may
put cleveland ahead of them but besides
that they're among the best in that in
the hunt group how do you see that afc
playoff picture yeah
yeah first keep that picture up i want
to continue to look at it in the hunt
the team that would probably scare me
the most out of all those teams it would
be the coats because i know they have a
solid defense they got guys that can
create turnovers big guys up front but
also offensively like we talked about
they can run the ball they can pound it
they can control the ground game and i
think the more they continue to play the
more they get continue to get familiar
with one another then they're going to
continue to get better but you look at
those cincinnati bingos boy that's who
i'm looking at them cincinnati bengals
who wants to play them in the wild card
game
i i i don't think anybody does right i
don't think anybody does i i you know
even even drew brees said on the show he
was like to me there's there's two to
the bengals are a complete team and
there's two teams at the top of the afc
and we talked about this in the post
game show over on peacock after the game
new england and cincinnati to me those
are the two most complete teams they're
young teams young quarterbacks but they
are coming together on the fly as you
watch pittsburgh fall apart as you watch
cleveland get all banged up specifically
at the quarterback position it just
illuminates further how far those teams
have come
and what i love about cincinnati is this
is a team
and i love what i'm seeing because
they're starting to come together as a
team they're starting to come together
as a team and when you see them the
celebrations and the dancing and the
hugs and no one caring about who gets
credit and everybody's happy for
everyone's success that's what i'm
talking about and you see a you see a
young quarterback get up there and face
the media and talk directly
in the camera to the
members of the media about his team and
how he feels just joe burrow basically
taking control they know who their
leader is and i love the fact that
they're coming together as a team man it
it is really really good to see a young
team coming together
it is it's exciting man it really is
okay let's get to our third one on turn
the page tuesday which is the los
angeles ram so we promised that we'd
come back for that other la team both
will be having their struggles right now
what's going on with the rams in your
opinion
it's the same thing like we just talked
about the charges i think matthew
stafford think about matthew stafford he
played in detroit where no one how many
games did you watch at matthew stafford
in detroit jack none right probably like
five i didn't enjoy any of them yeah
in in in a bunch of years and over a
dozen years but at the end of the day i
think
the pressure of playing in detroit
compared to the pressure plan in la with
the super bowl expectations that the
rams have and everything that they've
given up matthew stafford is a very
smart guy so he understands what they've
given up they went out and got odell
they went out and got von miller they
went out and traded the world for him
there's a lot of expectations and
look he's starting to revert back to the
matthew stafford in detroit
and i blame a lot of this on sean mcvay
we got to look at him he has to find a
way to toughen up his group and change
up some of the things that he's doing
because matthew stafford doesn't look
comfortable maybe it's the boot maybe
it's the play action maybe it's
something that he needs to change up but
matthew stafford does not look like the
same player and i'm looking at sean
mcvay because
i mean he hand-picked him he hand-picked
him yeah i know they lost robert woods
and robert woods was a very good player
but at the end of the day come on man
you got van jefferson you got odell
beckham you got to plug those guys in
and you got to be able to keep it moving
as a head coach
yeah i mean those are those are all very
good points and what i sort of find
myself going back to is when we were
going into that tennessee game which was
a few weeks ago on sunday night football
that we heard that stafford was having
some back pain some chronic back pain
and didn't really think much of it at
the time but as i've seen them start to
go downward as stafford's play has
started to go downward i can't help but
think i'm not sure how healthy he is and
and that's one of the things as you look
at what he's done these last three games
and that's really been since we started
hearing about some of the chronic back
pain
is that you may think that the grass is
always greener on the other side right
and i think that this was one of those
moves where the grass is going to be
greener if i can just go stafford well
the problem with that is there could
also be issues on the other side of that
fence when you have a 33 year old guy
who's been getting banged up in detroit
there may be a few negatives that are
going to follow him across the country
to la2 and it sounds like he has some
back issues that are starting to seep
into the play that we're seeing on the
field and that's not a great sign that's
not a great sign if you're sean mcveigh
is that what you think is that what you
think you think there's back issues
because everybody got back issues it's
an nfl season it's 17 weeks and you're
talking about matthew stafford has back
issues i got back ass shoes getting on a
plane going to west coast every single
week
like we all got i hear you i hear you if
hold on all i'm saying is this if you're
not if you're not ready okay if you're
not healthy don't go on a football field
okay because once again just like baker
mayfield all you're doing as a
quarterback you're hurting you're you're
hurting your team not going going out
there and not being you know 100 or
close to it
yeah i mean that's that's one of those
injuries though specifically at a
quarterback position when you have to
rotate if he actually has chronic back
issues
you could be looking at not only an
issue for the rams this season this
whole move think about what they gave up
to go get matthew stafford if he has
long term issues like this
i mean what would that mean for mcveigh
after this i mean they are they're
giving up everything then you go bring
in all these big personalities let's
insert odell beckham junior it's insert
von miller and it starts screwing around
with the chemistry you had built in that
locker room now you don't know who's a
leader you don't know who to listen to
man you do this mid-season after the
start you had it's ugly to watch and let
me say something that no one else is
saying
these two players that you brought in
they're not the same they're not the
same from when they first came in the
league von miller was he's got a hall of
fame first ballot no question about it
go von miller i'm a big fan but at the
end of the day von miller is not the
same player that we once saw
okay and that's why he was expendable in
in denver
denver's right there in the hunt we just
saw it and they let von miller go and
there was a reason for that you look at
odell beckham he's super athletic still
can catch one hand but he's still not
he's not the same player that he once
was so you go out you overpaid for these
young for these older players and
they're not what they used to be so
it'll be interesting to see what happens
the next month of the season because the
pressure's on mcvay and the pressures on
matthew stafford and if they don't get
it done this year man
we could see a new coach in la possibly
has all those he's got all those lower
extremity injuries that have eaten away
because what he was was twitchy right he
was one of those guys that was just so
athletically twitchy and just out there
on the autobahn could just explode by
people and go up and get the ball and do
amazing things you start having this
many serious lower leg injuries i don't
know that that twitch is the same that
it once was and he still wants the ball
like he's some young superstar and he's
an old guy who's been hurt a bunch of
times and so man i don't know it's hit a
break we'll come back for third and
short but the la rams in some serious
turmoil
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports